I vaguely thought something wasn't right
With so many believers gathering like this, I
don't have a natural enemy of
any kind.
There were only things I couldn't sympathize with
Why can't I use my psychic powers in my daily life?
From the desire,
I could feel the same heavy thing that lurks inside me
Wanting to be recognized My
own existence
[music]
After the sword of cool laughter This guy recognized me as a spirit Not
afraid,
not smoking, in the
end, this guy is me  When I accepted
you, I thought I could use you, but apart from
that, I felt something tense in my heart loosen.
That's
right, there's no reason to exist anymore There's still so much
I want to do
I'll listen to your ambitions What
as a friend
Hey
, I just wanted a friend
You're an amazing guy
Heh, quit